Okay, guys, welcome to call. I'm gonna get started. It's night after the hour. It is January 28, 2025. We're almost a month into this. You guys set goals to be at whatever by by Christmas or new the last day of 2025. You're already a month into this thing. We've already got a month gone. That means that whatever you were supposed to hit in Q1, you are now one third of the way
done. That's going to be exciting for some of you. It's going to be painful for others. But whatever the case is, we have a month gone. Anyway, it's shocking. I literally felt like New Year's was yesterday. That's crazy. Okay. Three things. Number one, rank and run engine. If you are new, quickly rank and run engine is our go to tool for this business. If you are outside the US, do not worry. We are working on rolling this out into different countries starting with the
pot, the the most densely populated countries for students inside this group, Australia, Canada, UK, etc, etc, etc, going from there. We are working on that. If you are outside the US and you're like, oh my gosh, I don't know how to do this without. Yeah, you can. Okay, ever. I was able to scale this thing using a bunch of tools cobbled together. It's not ideal, but it's doable. We have you in mind. We're working on it. If you're in the US and you're not using the tool that's on you. It's it's extremely, extremely, extremely, extremely
easy to manage everything one place, do your due diligence and just scale this business. Okay. What I want to say, the reason I'm bringing up ranking engine is I think I made this announcement last. No, I made the post last week, but I didn't make the announcement because by the way, last week guys, thanks to Porter and Jason, or maybe it's just border. I can't remember. I think it was both of them. They went live and in my place. I was actually traveling last Tuesday from Africa to Dubai, but here I am. What I want to say
though is our backlink analyzer tool is live. Okay. So for those of you guys that are paying for three to four tools, paying for majestic and paying for eight, eight trusts and paying for mangles and paying for a SEM rush and paying for a sauna and whatever. Stop. Okay. You're wasting money. You're wasting, uh, whatever you're wasting resources, but more importantly, you're wasting your attention. Right. You're, I remember trying to track down
stuff. Where's this document? Where's that sheet? Just make it easy guys. You can't put a price tag on convenience. You can't put a price tag on the time that you're saving. Um, all I wanted to do is give a shout out to Ryan. I went through the tool when he first launched it. And I very quickly was like, Hey, this tool is amazing. I love it. It's one place. It's simple. It's clean. It doesn't have all the extra crap. However, it's missing in the central component, which is the backlink analyzer. That was about six weeks ago when I told him this in six weeks, he
took my information. He took what I said to him. He designed it with the developers, took it to the developers, put it on a staging platform, took it into production. And it's already live within six weeks. That is the beauty of having this tool that we have in the group, because anything that we see, Hey, um, we need to add this. We need to change this. We need to get rid of this. We get to build it as we go. So the cool part is that's just version one of the backlink analyzer. And right now you'll notice in the backlink analyzer, you can look at the root
domain. We're going to be adding other ways, looking at the URL, the view from the URL, looking at the path view, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Some of you guys have no idea what I'm talking about. We're going to get into that more and more. Don't worry. Um, that tool is going to get beefed up. That's an individual tool inside of Rank Your Engine. Okay. All I want to say, if you guys get a chance, give Ryan a shout out. He got that thing done in six weeks. Um, you would never even be able to get stuff done with another company because they wouldn't care. And he was able to get that done in six weeks. And it is phenomenal. So guys go check that out.
If you already have an account, just go log into your account on the left-hand side at the bottom. It's the second one from the bottom and it's the backlink analyzer. Go in there, throw in your root domain and go and check out all the statistics, the trust flow, the citation flow, the referring domains, referring IPs, et cetera, et cetera, et cetera. Okay. Um, by the way, guys, we're, me and Ryan are going to be doing a proper training on how to use the backlink analyzer tool within Rank Your Engine.
We'll be here in the next few weeks, if not this week or next week, next Tuesday. So keep an eye out for that. Um, just so you guys know. Okay. And then again, I'm going to just drop this in the chat. For those of you that are wondering, do not have anything. I'm going to try to do this on my computer, see if it works. Here is the code. This is the code for the, uh, discount for Rank Your Engine. Okay.
Cool. I spent some time in there playing around with it. Just literally, even just today. So go check that out guys. RankYourEngine.com. I just dropped the code. You guys can go check that out. Um, last two things really quick.
Number one, I mentioned this two weeks ago, but guys, January is one of the best times of the year to get deals. When I talked about this two weeks ago, I literally told you guys, I was like, Hey, I have a business owner that I reached out to.
Literally this morning. And then if you guys remember at the end of the call, I picked up my phone. I had a response to that business owner. A couple of days later, I did a live with the business owner. I think it was like two days later.
I did a Zoom call. I'm sorry, with the business owner. And we, I basically said to them, Hey, I know we, things didn't work out in the past. We made some adjustments. Let me and Francesca look at the area you want to target.
Come up with a proposal and do a three month deal where you work with us for three months with the intention that at the end of the three months, we can work together for another six months to a year.
So we got this thing all teed up. We went in, we did the homework. When I say we, Francesca did all the homework and we have given them a proposal and we are supposed to hop on the phone later this week.
Just giving you guys an update. Reach out to those people that you reached out to back in January or back in July that were too busy, too fat and happy. July, August, September, October.
Reach out to them. Be a, I won't even say apologetic. Be a human and say, Hey, just wanted to circle back around. And you can tell me to go, I think the thing that I said, you can tell me to go and eat sand at any point.
But I do know that there's something we could work together on. If you're willing, I'd love to revisit this conversation, see what we could do and see if there's a way we work together again.
That's such an easy thing to say yes to. Okay. Reach out. January is a phenomenal time to get deals because there's something that clicks in people's brains between December 14th to 31st and January 1 to January 31st.
I don't know what it is. I can't explain it, but something changes inside of people. Okay. Reach out. It takes a second. It takes a little bit of hustle, takes a little bit of sweat and you're done. Okay.
Last thing I want to cover really quick is 3.0. It is coming along very nicely. I spent an hour on Monday. I spent an hour today. I'm spending one to one and a half hours per day working on the 3.0 version, working on auditing 2.0.
What can we get rid of? How can we make it shorter? How can we make it more to the point? What do we need to add? What, you know, all kinds of different stuff.
So I just want you to know that is in the works. It will be out before the end of quarter two. Sorry, end of quarter one before the start of quarter two.
Do not think there is something that you're missing in version 2.0 that version 3.0 is magically going to have that's going to make you millions of dollars by you not doing anything different.
Okay. Ninety five percent of the content is going to be the exact same. We are just going to be changing the way it is delivered and presented and the way you are going to consume it, which I think is going to radically change and help with the success of the students in this group.
We're going to be adding some stuff, taking some stuff away, but I don't want anyone sitting here, but I'm going to wait for 3.0. That is a stupid strategy. Go make some freaking money today.
Get ready, get excited for it. I am working on it at this point almost daily and looking super excited to releasing that for you guys. Okay, so that's it, guys. I'm going to bring on Zach Powell.
I think I'm going to intro Zach before I bring him on because it's always a little bit better for me to do it without embarrassing him. I am going to turn on the AC. You guys are going to give me about 10 seconds because I'm so hot in his office. Give me one second.
All right, guys, quick intro on Zach Powell. If you guys haven't listened to any of the trainings that we actually should probably check really quick to make sure you guys consider me. I can't see any comments, by the way.
I'm just kind of doing this off the seat of my pants. Okay, there we go. Let's see if I can see anything. People can still hear me. Let's see. Okay, I think we're still good.
11 minutes ago. If you guys can still hear me, I just have to keep canceling or deleting the app or killing it and bring it back on. But anyway, let me give you guys a quick intro on Zach and then Zach, he's in the waiting room. I'm going to be bringing him along with somebody that he's actually worked with personally.
Zach Powell is a, he's actually a member of this group. He's a student in here as of I think it was back in 2022 when he joined. But Zach, when he started, he was in a position where he needed to replace his income very rapidly. He had a job, we're going to get into his story, whatever.
He had a job that he needed to replace that income. He had like a severance or something, a few months worth. He's like, I got to replace my income by this date so I can keep doing this thing and my wife's not going to let me. Okay. And so he already bought a program.
And I think he bought one a year before that he purchased this one. And he looked at it and he's like, dude, the quickest way for me to be able to get out of my job to be able to replace that income is going to be through SEO. Okay.
Now, when I say SEO, I'm talking about taking the website, ranking it at the top of Google and doing it like as a, as a service. Okay. Not doing it where it's on your website, but doing it as a service for a client.
I used to be very, very against this because I tried to do this. It was actually what I tried to do to replace my income when I quit my door-to-door sales job.
But I did it incorrectly. I was targeting the wrong niches. I was going for the wrong type of deals. I was talking to the wrong type of people, but Zach did it in a very smart way.
He does it in this really smart, predictable way that he can literally, he's got this thing on autopilot and he's got actually has other people closing deals for him.
And so he's like just the puppet master behind the scenes that's pulling the strings. Okay.
And he does it in such a way that he perfectly tees these clients up to go and then sell digital assets to them that he builds.
He's making over 50k a month. He just barely built this brand new house for his family that he also uses and kind of like doubles as a office for his employees.
And you're probably going to see the background and everything. He used to be in an office and now he does that.
But on top of that, guys, he's one of the most humble dudes I know. He's a family guy and he's literally living the life of his dreams.
He's surfing or mountain biking in a new country. It seems like almost every week. It's probably more like every month or every month, but he's living the life that you want to live.
I think it's really cool. So today, Zach is going to be teaching us and he's going to be talking about this as someone that's doing over 50k a month, how to become a $50,000 per month sales monster.
And I'm just going to be over here enjoying. I don't even have questions prepared because Zach hasn't prepared.
But as questions come, I'm going to be asking if you guys have questions, I want you to drop them.
Just know this guy has my stamp of approval and I don't let a whole lot of people have any kind of a platform inside of this group because I don't trust a lot of people.
This is somebody that I actually trust. So I'll be bringing Zach on.
And I'm also going to be bringing on Vinny, who is also ironically a student of this program in digital landlords.
He joined back in 2022 as well. Zach helped him and showed him how to do what he did.
And Vinny has also has also replaced his income and is making a lot of money doing these very simple SEO deals.
OK, so let me bring these guys in really quick. Get your questions ready and let's get into this right now.
Zach Powell.
Hey, Nick. Hey, Vinny. How's it going, guys? What's up? Oh, Vinny, there you are, bro. Can you hear me?
I hear you. How's it going, Nick? It's going great. I'm going to give. Good to see you, bro. It's been a minute.
Good to see you, Vinny. Zach, I see you a lot. Vinny, I haven't seen you in a minute. Good to see you, dude. It's been a while. Yeah, you too.
So real quick, I'm going to give Zach co-host just because of my Internet glitches.
Then, Zach, you can keep going. I'll jump back on. I don't know. I have Internet troubles.
It's it's wild here in Dubai, which you'd never think would be the case.
So anyway, Zach, welcome to Call Dude from tuning in from Queen Creek, Arizona.
And Vinny, tell everyone where you're at right now. I'm right next to Zach. I'm in Gilbert, Arizona.
Have you always been there or did you move there recently?
No, I moved here about two years ago.
Did you move there after you started working with Zach or before?
So I actually first met Zach like a year before I moved here officially.
I was here visiting and we met up and then I moved later.
I love it, dude. It's a great area. It's a it's a cool area.
Yeah, I'll take the heat all day over the snow. So I get the drop.
Zach, I gave you an intro. Vinny, maybe you can just kind of and I don't know if you guys are on,
but Vinny was a member of and is a member of Digital Landlords.
He also started working with Zach. Zach started kind of mentoring him on what he does
and landing these very simple SEO deals and was able to scale his agency up.
And Vinny, not to put you on the spot, but maybe you can let everyone know
kind of where your agency sits right now in terms of revenue just to give some context.
Yeah, I'm at about forty four thousand monthly recurring right now.
Most of that is directly due to both of you guys.
Yeah, bro. Forty four thousand per month. That's insane, dude.
Last time I talked to you, you're making like eight or something like that.
Zach, what are you at right now per month?
We're at fifty eight.
Fifty eight. So Vinny's biting at the heels, dude. Let's go. He's coming.
I know. He's coming for me. It's awesome. I love seeing it.
What a lot of people don't know because I've had people like, for example,
Ryan Dalton, he's he went up to eighty seven K like two years.
It's actually the biggest flex ever is when somebody that you've helped makes crazy money.
It's not intimidating or threatening. It's like the best.
It's like when your kid scores a basket, you know, in bad years, just balls.
So I'm like, hey, it works. It works. Keep doing it. It works.
It's 100 percent, man. So it's going to be exciting.
It's going to be exciting. So we have between the three of us,
we're making a fair amount of money doing a very simple thing on the Internet.
Now, Zach and Vinny are there.
They're working with clients in a very strategic way where they manage their SEO, their websites.
They've got it. They've got it really dialed in where they don't have to do a whole bunch of,
you know, back and forth. We'll talk more about that.
We've talked about that in their lives. We're going to keep this mainly on sales.
I'm obviously doing the same thing, but on my own websites.
OK, the thing I like about what you guys are doing, though,
and the reason why I've always kind of giving you a stamp of approval, Zach and Vinny,
is because you guys are doing it in a very strategic and smart way.
When I was doing SEO, I was just going for big clients.
I was going for the big, juicy four thousand dollar per month, high maintenance,
you know, prima donna clients, and it just didn't work.
And it was terrible. You guys are building these brick by brick businesses.
I bet you your forty four thousand dollars, for example, Vinny,
is spread out in such a way that if you lost a client today, you're not going to lose sleep.
Am I wrong on that or is that pretty accurate?
That's exactly right. Yeah. Yeah, I love that.
So I've talked enough. I want to turn the time over to Zach, Vinny. I'll chime in.
It was questions, but I'm going to shut my mouth.
You guys are the ones that are combining right now for over one hundred thousand dollars per month,
doing just basic, simple five hundred, three hundred, six hundred dollar a month
SEO deals with business owners. So you guys are doing a lot of deals.
Let's talk about how to become a sales monster. Fifty thousand dollars per month sales monster.
Awesome, man. Yeah, thanks for bringing me out. Appreciate it.
So I think real quick, I'll just talk about like what Vinny and I have done
and then we'll talk about how to become a sales monster and sales beast.
So essentially, you know, I started with Legion and it was tough for me.
And I was like getting all these easy opportunities to win SEO deals.
My dad's a carpet cleaner. So I was like, sure, I'll do your website, dad.
And then his friends and they just started stacking up and I saw the route to quit my job,
which was my main goal. And so I just kept taking all these SEO clients
and systemized it where it was just like stacking easy wins, easy wins, easy wins.
And so Vinny has done the same model and has crushed it.
There's more info. I'll just throw it in the chat if you want to check out.
I like showing my strike page and stuff. ZachPowell.co.
There's super basic landing page, has like my strike page, tells my story.
Check it out if you want. But I guess Vinny, if you. Cool.
And then Vinny, if you want to kind of tell about your journey of like Legion,
what appealed with SEO, what you did, how it helped you scale, that'd be great.
And then I can go into like some sales training that I prepared.
So you have any thoughts on, I guess, the Grow SEO program or like how it helped you
being in digital landlords and being in Grow SEO and kind of your thoughts on that?
Yeah, yeah, for sure. So, you know, getting started like you in Legion,
obviously it takes time to kind of start ranking these sites and then you can rent them out.
And then Nick comes along and teaches like to speed that up with the ads, which works great.
I landed some awesome clients that way. It is kind of expensive, right?
To get going. And then you kind of introduced me to focusing more on SEO,
which doesn't really take much expense or time.
You can just come in and you start working on the client site right away.
You know, they're paying you from day one, regardless of where the site is ranking.
So it was just a good way for me to kind of start building my client base quickly and with little overhead.
So I really kind of hit that hard after I saw the first few deals come through and it was going smooth.
And the rest is history. Great, great coaching program.
I've learned so much from you, from both of you guys.
You know, as far as SEO and selling more than anything, you got to be able to sell.
And that's what I've learned. Like until you have a sale, you don't have a business.
So there have been many times where I've sold something before I even knew how I was going to deliver.
And like, that's OK. You know, if you're committed to delivering, then get the sale and then you figure it out.
So that's been my biggest takeaway from both of you guys.
Just get the sale and then move forward.
Does that kind of cover what you wanted, Zach?
Anything else? Yeah, man, that's awesome.
Yeah, I love what you said about sales, too, because sales is like that foundation.
When you have those confidence and knowledge, you'll just go crush it.
So I'll prepare some thoughts on that today.
Usually I share my screen on my iPad, but I'm just going old school with some paper today.
We're going to talk about being a sales beast.
So first thing to talk about.
Let me do this quick, Zach. Let me try to unshare or let me.
I'm seeing in the chat somebody said, I can't see you.
And I don't know why that is.
Porter says, I can't see you and hear bits and pieces.
I can hear you guys. Can you guys hear me?
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
Maybe whoever else is on, maybe Porter needs to get out of the freaking jungle wherever he's at
and get off the track and watch this on some actual Wi-Fi.
That could be part of the problem.
But just in case it's not just a Porter problem.
Just kidding, Porter.
Can anyone else confirm that you can hear us before Zach gets into this?
So that I'm not being the only ones getting this training.
It might be good for us to check it out.
If you can hear us, let me know.
If you can see us, let me know.
By the way, I have to keep killing my app and then refreshing.
My Facebook lives are probably the worst thing that's ever happened, but also convenient.
So let's see here.
So Kevin says he can only see me.
We can hear, just not see you.
You guys can see me though, right?
Yeah, I can see all three of us.
Let me take off the...
That's so wild, dude.
We're just voices in Nick's head right now.
That's crazy.
Okay, well, only see you, Nick Wood.
That's wild, dude.
That's wild.
Okay, let me try to get one more thing.
Hold on.
I'm going to remove spotlight from me, remove spotlight from you.
And then there's three of us.
Okay, let's see if that works because I did the spotlight thing.
One more time.
Can you guys see us?
Can you guys hear us?
Before we continue here.
Let's see.
Sorry about that, guys.
The game here.
So Jason, I read last comments that we can hear, just not see you.
By the way, Zach and Vinny, can you guys see the comments coming in real time?
I can't.
I can't, yeah.
I'm Facebook.
I don't have it pulled up.
Okay.
Zach, as soon as you get a confirmation, I'm going to have to keep killing the app.
I can't even see anything in real time.
If anyone confirms they can see us now, then we can move forward.
The last comment I see is from Jason.
Yeah, everyone is just saying they just see you.
But they can hear us.
I mean, I'm fine to just talk it out and they can look at you smiling if they want.
You know what I can try to do, brother, is you have co-hosts.
So here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to hop off.
You just start your thing and then you just let me in.
And let's see if that solves the problem.
I'm good.
I'm actually going to make you host, not just co-host.
Let me try that really quick.
See if that solves the problem.
One more time, guys.
Can you see Zach now?
Because it says I'm the host, or it says Zach's the host.
If they can't, I'm going to just hop off.
You guys just start going and then I'll hop on and see if it'll keep it on you.
Because you're going to be the one doing the primarily talking.
Any other comments in there?
Still just you that they can see.
Okay, I'm going to hop off.
You just get going, Zach.
Obviously, if I hop off, they're going to have to see somebody.
So they have to see you.
If it goes black, let me know.
I'll hop right back on.
Just let me back in here in a second, okay?
Sounds great.
Great.
Actually, you know what, Zach?
You better start.
Can you push record, please, so we can record it on your end?
Oh, yeah.
Record to the cloud.
Here we go.
It says I can't record to the cloud here.
Can you record to your computer?
Yeah, I can do that.
Let's see.
Record to this computer.
That worked.
Recording.
Here we go.
All right.
Sounds good.
I'm going to hop off.
See you in a second, guys.
All right.